move so me that's that's more of a point
to why I think there's less wives so I
think traditionally and even currently
men caught women we go out and we try to
find a woman so if we can't find a woman
I think that's the problem now it's like
we're not we're not making it blunt
enough like
men don't want to get married to the
current women and we have multiple
reasons for that like let's not talk
about only fans let's not talk about
masculine women like it's it's simple
like we just don't think women are good
enough now for us to settle down and
marry so do you think that women don't
think they're good enough for men or men
don't think they're good or do you think
it's um because I think that like women
don't think men are good enough for them
even if they're average
yeah that's the problem isn't it yeah
yeah I think because if you look in
history I don't
I think women dated and married average
guys historically because a lot of
question I ask on my show often is like
how much does your submission cost
and uh and I say like to the point that
like he said quit your job tomorrow I'll
be with the kids you do it yeah I've
seen you ask them for the Saturday night
and they always say six figures even if
they're fives even though that's a
percent how much people how much men in
the world on six figures yeah and uh so
then the next question is always are you
a top 10 girl and they say no and so
it's like you have girls that are not
top 10 asking for a top 10 outcomes in
order to submit I think the word submit
bothers women just the word submit
bothers them this misconstrued to be
honest I think they uh I've heard this
before someone I'm not sure where but uh
I heard that women tend to think
submission means slavery like they think
what the months is is just absolutely
final without reason you know what I
mean when submission really is just um
you know it's not that you don't get to
say in the matter it's just that there's
a leader and you're second in command
there's someone in primary command but
you're still in second in command
and you have a lot of influence too it's
like like because you can
I mean ever every person knows like that
couple that's like really cute we're
like even even though the guy's in
charge like the woman's kind of in
charge because she's just so feminine
and kind of can can get her him to like
see her point of view there's a couple
that comes to your head right I said
okay I'm gonna give you an example it's
a little bit extreme but you actually
see the very clear actually this will
it's controversial if you think about it
but it's the healthiest relationships
are from the BDSM
community and I will I will explain why
because I need to find healthy no no so
I need you to like if so I'm gonna claim
this the reason why I say it's healthy
is in order to be able to be in that
type of relationship because it is so
extreme to the point where sometimes
there is a chance of death yeah because
people engage in such extreme activities
you need extreme trust in order to get
into it is there is there any data that
backs this up so the the idea no this
just sounds like this sounds crazy to me
so I I know I'm I'm going to give you
the example okay because things are so
extreme you're not just going to do it
even though it's a fantasy you're not
going to do it unless you trust that
person it's not going to actually kill
you does that make sense so you have to
discuss all the details you you say what
do I like what I don't like they talk
about what are the things that you might
consider what are the things what is a
hard no what is a soft no what is and
after you've done all of that and you
agree that you're going to give it a try
you have to have a safe word
so what happens in that relationship one
person's the Dom one person's a sub
who holds the power
the Dumber is that just sexually though
no no no that's that's yes that's that's
that's a trick question the ultimate
power is the sub why because they can
determine when it stops exactly and
that's the beauty of submission ladies
it's the beauty of
submitting because you know that you
trust that person so much that you
literally trust them with your life
and it's beautiful because you say to
this man I am willing to submit to you I
trust you ultimately for my livelihood
and my well-being ultimately I trust you
100 and I know that if because it is
negotiable if I am uncomfortable even
slightly and I don't I want to get out
of it I want to step away you have my
back you will respect me and you are
going to give me that ability to walk
away and just just to add to that
um
think when women hear submission they
just think like
demands in front and they're just behind
like I'm telling you women that does not
that's not what submission means like
and there's certain points like I said
before that men actually like you to be
uh in the Forefront so like I said
before in a fam you go to a family
gathering right we don't want to be
putting up plates for the kids and
making sure everyone's fed like that's
that's when you can dominate the
situation it doesn't mean we have to be
headhunt all the time it just means the
majority of the time
wear your safety we're there for you to
protect you we're there to provide for
you so it hasn't got to be all the way
like where you're just traveling along a
way like in front of you there can be
certain points where they dominate so um
I'm curious for you why do you think
there's a shortage of
um wives
I don't I think they're uh jeopardizing
their chances to be white but I think
there's a lot of potential husbands but
you could also make the argument there's
a shortage of both because they're being
turned off because
does that make sense because of the law
yeah yeah and so
yeah but I think the more women are
jeopardizing their potential to be wives
but I think there's loads of potential
husbands who can actually get into the
husband role like they could be but it's
just they don't have the right girl to
become that exactly what what mistakes
do you see girls make that takes them
out of the running to be wives
um I don't know I just wanna
if I could just
simply say it well if they're if they
could easily get sucked into things like
feminism like you know overall yeah I
know people say oh but there's this type
of feminism
you know I think we could all agree that
all this like men are trash and all that
stuff that's probably the biggest
mistake if you can if you can allow that
in you know in your mindset and think
that that's okay that's probably the
biggest one
that turns men off because you can even
just say that's that that's enough
because in feminism they say you don't
have to do this he could just accept you
the way you are you don't have to do
anything you just have to exist and
going back to the actual topic of what
we were talking about the bar is set
very just ridiculously high for men to
the point where I I I think that they
deliberately do that to take the piss
it's just so high it's unattainable but
for women I feel like there is no but it
doesn't even exist so you can see that
there you see the girls on my 300 pound
life with a man I
is that monthly no I haven't even seen
that
yeah I personally I personally think
that the problem these days in modern
culture whatever you want to call it is
that people is actually focusing on the
wrong things so these girls are talking
about and I think there was recently
these guys who came in and said they
were high value men and they wear flashy
stuff they act you know a certain way
and I can tell you that a high value
woman the ones that you actually the
good ones that you want as a wife
they're not going to say yes to that guy
because they're gonna see him and be
like oh he's so insecure he needs to
drive a Lambo in order to feel